their expressing gratitude for 25 years
of Peace but those working to bring
divided unionists and nationalist
communities together believe
reconciliation is a long way off I don't
think that work of healing was ever done
in drawing our communities together and
in
uniting our hopes for the future in us
saying that the other is New Or should
be no threat that we can coexist in the
way that many communities across the
world manage to achieve
the hatred and distrust was born of a
30-year conflict
3700 people died more than half of them
civilians paramilitaries from the Irish
Republican Army wanted the British army
out
Protestant gunmen mounted their own
campaign
it ended with what some observers called
a political miracle
power sharing was the central prop but
the main players Democratic unionists in
the dup and nationalists in Shin Fein
have been at odds right now the seat of
devolved government at Stormont is
defunct after the dup walked out in a
dispute about EU trade laws and brexit
Alan McBride is among those accusing
politicians of letting their people down
in 1993 an IRA bomb in Belfast shankill
Road killed nine people his wife Sharon
was one of them we have a relative peace
here in this County at imminent we we
don't have reconciliation we still have
Shen fee in the deep in each other's
throats it's very simple I believe that
we need uh more kindness in our politics
and I think for far too long uh both
shin fian and the dup have only ever
really cared about what matters to them
the big question is still this how can
Republicans and unionists somehow accept
their respective Traditions their
cultures their identities when they're
synonymous with such a violent history
on Tuesday the U.S President Joe Biden
will be visiting Northern Ireland he's
known to be concerned about the effects
of political instability on The Good
Friday peace agreement
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera Belfast